-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Isla Fisher.
So, you mentioned saying
to an agent,
"Can you get me
a comedy audition?"
But I also heard
your first agent you got
when you were 11 years old,
just via the Yellow Pages.
-[ Laughs ] Exactly.
That's how you do it
in Perth, Australia.
You go through the Yellow Pages,
you find someone.
I took a bunch of photos
holding, like, a potted plant
or whatever inanimate object
I could get my hands on
and then proceeded
to send them to her
and called her every day,
going, "I want to be a clown!
Have you got me a job yet?"
No, I was very enthusiastic
back then.
Yeah, and that's sort of how
I started out as a kid actor.
-And you were on
an Australian soap opera
that a lot of incredibly
accomplished actors
got their start on,
"Home and Away."
But you were not resting
on your lo--
laurels, excuse me,
as a young actor.
You wrote books
at a very young age.
-Were you going to say, "You
were not resting on your loins"?
[ Laughing ] I was like --
-I was gonna say "loins."
I -- Look, I have a bad back,
and my doctor said I have to
rest on my loins more often.
-[ Laughs ]
Okay, I --
Yes, you're right.
I wrote romance novels
with my mother -- two of them,
"Seduced by Fame" and
"Bewitched" -- when I was 18,
which was actually
very embarrassing
'cause I was a pretty
inexperienced teenager.
Not surprising,
given my penchant for clowns.
So, when she would -- we had to
write these romance scenes,
which were quite -- well, let's
just say they got hot and heavy.
I had no idea
what Mum was pitching.
Some of the things she said,
I was so --
I just didn't --
It was so awkward.
Anyway.
Now, of course,
I've actually moved into
sort of short-form kids books,
and I've written four
"Marge in Charge," a series,
and I'm just developing a show
now with Nickelodeon.
So, I still --
I still love to write,
but thankfully not sex scenes,
and not with my mum.
-So, you do have children now,
and I'm wondering,
are they of the age where
they read "Marge in Charge"?
And if so, do they like them?
-Does -- I, mean I feel
like I started --
I started them, oh, gosh,
at least six years ago now.
And so a lot of the voice of
Marge came out of, you know --
You know how you do impressions
for your kids at bedtime?
-Yes.
-You know, Peppa Pig
or, like, their friends' parents
or whatever to get a laugh.
Marge sort of began as a voice,
and then, yes,
she turned into these books.
And so they were
and they are a --
continue to be a hit
in the house.
So, I'm very grateful.
But equally,
they're very good critics,
and I get told
when something isn't funny
or some character
can't do something
when I read the stories
before I hand them in.
They're the real editors.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
-It's nice both that they have
the comfort to tell you that,
and I think it's equally nice
that you trust their opinion.
I think that speaks
to a very strong
parent-child relationship.
-Aw, thanks, Seth.
-I'm also very -- I have a lot
of respect for your family
because you have the same kind
of dog that I grew up with.
You have a sheepdog.
Is it Maisy?
Is that the name?
-Maisy, yes!
Yeah!
[ Laughs ]
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
-So, this is -- this picture
put me in the best mood
because, you know, my parents
still do this
with their sheepdog.
It is --
I think people are shocked
when they see exactly
how little these dogs are
underneath all that hair.
-Right!
They're just like "Who are you?"
Underneath the burly fur
is a wafer-thin dog.
But truthfully, I feel like
she'd be really insulted
if she knew
that I shared that picture.
I feel like I have to
run everything by her
before I post it on Instagram,
because she --
You can see she just
feels so self-conscious.
But we had to shave her,
unfortunately,
because she got dreadlocks.
And anyway, you know what it's
like with an English sheepdog.
It's grooming daily.
-Yeah.
I feel like half of the time,
my mother was just
straddling the dog,
like, just working out --
Like, my memories of my mom
growing up were, like,
just her, like, just fighting
this losing battle with --
-I know, that's what --
It's just brushing.
Like, I look in the mirror
and I think,
"I haven't brushed my hair,
but Maisy's fur is beautiful."
[ Both laugh ]
-Now, "Wolf Like Me."
This is a --
Is it right that this was
a friend of yours
who had this idea, someone
you've known for a long time?
-Yeah, Bruna Papandrea.
She's a fantastic producer.
She did "Big Little Lies"
and "Nine Perfect Strangers."
And she came to me with this --
you know, with this idea
that was --
it was very, you know, specific.
Again, I can't really
give it away.
But I just connected to it.
And I really love
the director's --
you know, his film
and just his take on it.
And it just felt like --
you know, it just felt
like the right step.
You know, I prefer, honestly, to
work in comedy, but this was --
for a dramatic role,
it was very complex,
and she's a great character,
you know, to portray.
-You mentioned it early on
when we were talking.
We did meet on the set of
"Hot Rod," which is a film --
-Yeah, you are
the greatest writer.
-Oh, that's very kind of you.
-You -- No, I'm just
gonna say this now.
I had never had
a creative experience
and haven't really since
like the one where
I sat in a room with you
and you were just --
'cause at that point
with the character Denise,
we didn't know
if she was gonna be comedic
or whether she was gonna
be more the straight man,
'cause Rod was, you know,
a heightened character.
Anyway, and you
were just like --
you could write a joke
for any type of character,
for any scene.
You know, and they were
character-based humor,
but there was also just, like,
puns and just sight gags.
And I just feel like
you are so brilliant.
Anyway.
-That was not --
That was not
what I was fishing for,
but it turned out great for me.
This is --
I'm just gonna say,
this is the best Raya date
I've ever been on.
I should've dressed up for it.
But I will say, you know,
I think we can both admit,
"Hot Rod" did not take
the box office by storm.
It has really grown
into a cult classic,
and I hope you hear as many
nice things about it as I do.
-Continually.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, more than anything
I've ever done,
I get asked about "Hot Rod."
And people --
when Halloween comes around
and every time I go to a party,
there's Denise and Rod
or just Rod.
I mean, I feel like it really
got into the zeitgeist
and became --
Is it a classic?
I don't know if that's
too strong a word,
but it's definitely --
Everybody seems to use it
as their comfort comedy film
to cheer themselves up
again and again.
-Well, it's very --
it's very special
to have had even a small part
in something like that.
And it's really great
to see you again, Isla.
Thank you so much
for making time for us today.
-Thank you, Seth.
Thank you so much.
Take care, mate.
-Isla Fisher, everybody.
"Wolf Like Me" begins streaming
on Peacock tomorrow.